There is a kind of glorification of the
weakness of [music] men in western
society.
>> They've taught men that if you want to
be attractive, you have to be weak.
Trans and sex, gender confusion, it's
all by design, I believe. Who are the
arbiters of any society? It's the men.
If you want to control a society, the
number one thing I'd want to do is to
emasculate the men. The Muslims because
they're kind of like a little more
primordial. Western man his problem is
he's so corrupt and emasculated and he
feminized and just you know doesn't has
lost his mooring with being a man
whereas Islam the only decent thing
about it is has this it's very you know
try getting away with this gender
nonsense in a Muslim country you know
give me a break or this trans stuff no
way and I respect that that they do that
they don't tolerate that sort of thing
so yeah and that's kind of the appeal of
the Muslim is that you know on the one
hand he's not he doesn't put up and and
it's also a reflection of the western
man. Just as the western man puts up
with the Muslims nonsense, so the
western man puts up with all kinds of
stupidity in the name of tolerance,
etc., etc., which is why he's getting
trampled upon so easily.
>> There is a kind of glorification of the
weakness of men in Western society.
>> Yeah. And but I think that's intentional
because they've taught men that if you
want to be attractive, you have to be
weak. But that's so we can walk all over
you and control you. Who's who are the
arbiters of any society? It's the men.
If you want to control a society, if I'm
this evil, you know, evil Dr. genius,
whatever, Dr. Evil, and I want to
control a society, the first the number
one thing I'd want to do is to
emasculate the men and to convince the
men that, hey, maybe acting like a woman
is kind of cool. All right? Because uh
that right there is the easiest way to
control and and and then and try to
empower the women and create just to
create chaos so that nothing even makes
sense and no and everyone's demoralized
and women and men don't get along and
families fall apart. Okay. So that's why
I think even this whole like trans and
sex gender confusion, it's all by
design. I believe a lot of this is by
design.
>> See, it has to be.
>> I don't I'm not buying that
>> because it's gone. So it's so I used to
think all this is organic. Okay. It's
kind of like a natural development that
that assumes philosophy gone wrong.
There's somebody behind it.
>> Yeah. There's
>> like a cabal of Illuminati or somebody
pulling strings. Everyone's a marinet.
Marionette like that. I'm just not I'm
just not
>> You don't believe in conspiracy
theories?
>> See, the problem a lot of people tell me
I don't believe in conspiracy theories.
And I'm not talking about any specific
conspiracy theory. But when you say I
don't believe in a conspiracy theory,
and that's a popular thing to say if you
want to sound rational. What you're also
saying by default is that I believe
everything is transparent and being
shown to me.
>> Because if you and who can believe that?
You'd have to be a fool to believe that.
But if there if everything isn't
transparent and there's two or more
people working together behind the
scenes, which obviously makes much sense
whether they're political figures or
not, that's a conspiracy.
>> So I guess if you mean what if you mean
by conspiracy,
I'm fairly confident that the genesis of
this madness is from the university that
>> Yeah. Oh. Oh. Well, that's a that's a
powerful, you know, tool
>> that groups of deranged people get
together and they fabricate bodies of
literature. the idea have written about
that
>> and Hollywood you know the okay the
>> but Hollywood is downstream of academia
>> no I know
>> because the people get out of academia
and go into Hollywood
>> yeah or or you can see them as you know
they're they're kind of the two arms of
the same kind of body one is geared
towards uh stupifying academics and
intellectuals want to be smart and one
is for the masses Hollywood but they
both have the same message right and I
I'll give you another example on this
topic that we're talking about and to
show you like uh so If you look at
history and you look today, every
culture, every civilization, they
venerate their forefathers and their
ancestors, right? I mean, this is like a
it's across the board and no one would
argue or complain and say you're bad for
doing that, even if their ancestors are
bad. It's a natural instinct. It makes
sense. You know, we it's part of our
continuity, our bloodline, our heritage,
etc. And, you know, and I see this a lot
with the Muslim world and and the kind
of Muslims that they venerate are pretty
nasty people. I mean, we're talking
about mass slavers, uh, you know, like
someone like Mhmed or Muhammad II, the
Ottoman Sultan, who, let's just take my
word for I don't want to waste time on
it, but I write about him a lot. The
stuff he did is pretty despicable and
abominable, but he's got statues
everywhere in Turkey. Okay? Now, you
come to the West [laughter] where they
actually have really good ancestors they
should celebrate and they're hated and
there so much disdain and you know,
George Washington statue, Abraham
Lincoln, whatever have to go down,
Churchill. Okay,
>> Lincoln in in in uh Portland, they
ripped down the statue of Lincoln.
>> Said he's a Nazi. There's this watch
sticker with a line through it there.
>> But here's the thing, you know what?
Let's forget what they really are or
what they weren't. My point is people
don't do that to their ancestors even
when they know they're bad because it's
part of our it's our it's our team and
we're we got our guy. He's our guy.
Okay.
>> But we do that to our ancestors. We love
doing that to our ancestors.
>> And the question is why? Because but
there's an important reason when you
tear down your ancestors and your
history. Yeah.
>> Okay. You've just you've renounced your
leg, your heritage. You've said no to
it.
>> They want to renounce. They want to they
think that the system itself is the
cause that needs to be dismantled and
disrupted.
>> Right. But a lot of this
>> and that's being [snorts] taught in the
university.
>> Exactly. And that's the fake history
that I'm always combating because fake
history makes people hate their
ancestors and it was intentional to make
you so they lie about the past.
>> And the way that they try to
make it so that everything you you're
writing about and speaking about doesn't
have to be taken seriously is they call
you farright.
>> Right. Yeah. Yeah. Or or everything, you
know, let's say slavery. You know, you
mentioned slavery on campus. Oh,
everyone knows about slavery. They know
about the transatlantic slavery. That's
it. And the idea is only white people
ever engaged in slavery.
>> Did Muslims tell us a little bit about
Muslims?
>> Yeah, much more than whites ever did.
And they enslaved tons of whites. In the
16th century alone, there was 1.2
million whites in Barbrey, North Africa,
who were kidnapped by Muslims, and they
were all taken from Europe. As far as
Iceland, they would go and Denmark.
>> Many on the left would argue that's a
good thing. [laughter]
>> So, it's bad when whites enslave blacks,
but when blacks enslave whites, that's a
good thing. It's a kind of
egalitarianism of slavery. Like you it's
not so so that whites took a lot of I'm
not saying I believe that.
>> No, I know you said a lot of people say
that.
>> So so it it it's it's not that uh so so
whites took a lot of blacks and it's
only fair that other non people should
take white people as slaves. I see for
attack. Yeah. That equals everything
out. So
>> right. But what I'm saying is they did
it first. the Muslims and the Africans
were actually enslaving whites before
the transatlantic slave trade.
>> So then they would have to make the
argument that's
>> it was still good obviously because it
was it was multiculturalism you know but
[laughter]
>> so okay so when you present people with
this argument that there were actually
Muslim slave traders and a lot of them
who took a a significant number of white
people. What what is the response? Is it
they deserved it? Is it, you know,
deniialism? No, that's not true.
>> Is it What is the response?
>> In my experience, the response, and I'm
the one who's really been doing this,
uncovering lots in the in the historical
field. The best response for them is
nothing. Just act like they never heard
it and never never um you know, they
won't debate me. They won't read. That's
why if you can get that guy or anyone,
I'm more than happy to.
>> So, you're willing to debate the what
whatever that dude's name is. I don't
remember his name. So, you're willing to
come on and debate the guy?
>> Absolutely. I can't tell you what's
going to happen.
>> What's going to happen?
>> They're going to say I didn't reach out
to him.
>> Oh,
>> they're going to say, "Well, yeah, but
they're going to say, you know, he he
sent us emails, but the emails were
never responded to." I can already tell
you.
>> I know that's happened to me before with
other people. I know. I know. I know.
>> You didn't really send him. You didn't
really mean
>> because how do you win? Here's the
thing. when we come to facts in history,
you know, and if you're smart, if if I
was in that guy's position going against
me and I see what I'm saying, what am I
going to say? I mean, the facts the the
record is the record. So, that's why
their strongest um apologetic or defense
or damage control is denial and ignoring
it and don't even look at it. Don't talk
to him, suppress him. when I was invited
to give a talk at the war college, the
US Army War College about about history
care the the Council on American Islamic
Relations and all these leftist groups
flipped out and called me a racist and a
white supremacist and but they couldn't
say it was about my book sword and
scimitar white supremacist.
>> Yeah, me but they couldn't find anything
wrong in my book. They didn't say, "Oh,
on page so and so he lied." It's funny
how the semantic range of that term has
>> Yeah. An Egyptian guy has become a white
supremacist
>> continuously from, you know,
Scandinavians or Germans.
>> Yeah. Because these words are just made
to shut you down. That's it. And that's
why another thing I would say,
>> you know, it's sad because, you know,
things like uh racism do exist, right?
But these words are being so overplayed
and being weaponized and it's, you know,
the only way around it is I think people
need to just not care. Sticks and stones
may break my bones with words. You know,
you should people should take an
attitude where you know what, if you
want to call me racist, call me a
racist. You want to call me anything,
call me anything.
>> So, here's here's
>> But I'm above and beyond.
>> Here's a problem problem with that. So,
we're going to do an event tomorrow.
It's a comedy solar.
>> You don't disclose your whereabouts
because some lunatic could saw your head
off.
>> And yet, we've posted your name and face
to like I don't even know how many
people at this point, right? And so now
we have to be concerned about getting
security so that no one murders you or
blows himself up in the middle of the
comedy solo,
>> right? [laughter]
>> And what does that tell us about the
current situation now when you go back
to the small minority and say, "Oh, in
America, I think Muslims are 1%." And we
have situations like that. So uh you
know,
>> I think that was the book the the case
with the Book of Mormon when no you know
what did Mormons do? They took out an
ad. But no, nobody is worrying about
Mormons killing anybody else,
>> right?
>> But again, I guess the retort I can hear
the retort now is that this is such a
small number of people who are radical
and there's a small number of any
religion who's radical.
Okay, this is like this this is like
someone telling me, "Hey, I'm going to
give you a a jar full of candy. There's
like a hundred little pieces of candy
and only two are poison. Only three are
going to kill you. What's the big deal?
Just let's all eat from it." What if I
say I don't want to take the chance? I'd
rather not have all those sweets that
and but also not die.
>> Yeah. But in the case of the UK and then
I'm going to ask you a question about
Palestinians.
>> What is what do they get? What what does
the UK get in return for what they
taken?
>> What?
>> Well, I mean you're you're asking them
exotic
guy. I mean
>> I'm trying to think what there should be
a reciprocal. Okay. I understand what
migrants are getting.
>> I don't know. Replacing the population.
>> [laughter]
>> uh some kind of economic advant although
that's not true when you look at the the
data for incarceration rates and for who
contributes to the treasury but so is it
true that if you looked at a population
like Palestinians
same culture same history same language
same tradition same everything but it
and again this is outside my area but
there are not many if any Christian
suicide bombers but there are Muslim
suicide bombers so that
>> you can point to the one very Like when
you quote unquote science something, you
want to keep all of the variables the
same and change only one of the
variables.
>> Exactly. And what what is it? It's
Islam. And but you can't say that. I
understand that people don't want to say
that. But just like you pointed out,
there's a lot of why where's the
Palestinian Christian suicide bomber?
Well, because it's just not part of
their thing. It's part of
>> And the way the way that people respond
to that is they don't talk to you and
call you far right because they can't
respond to it with reason, evidence, and
argument or they would be coming on the
show and talking. And the reason that we
would want them to come on the show is
like you don't really want them.
Actually, I do. You against one of these
guys would get a crazy number of views.
So, actually, it is in my own interest.
>> Bring it on. I'd love it. Anybody?
>> Yeah. They won't come. They won't come.
Final.